c'est maintenant que vous prenez votre
décision si Benaim Gan
finalement il n'y aura rien
rien pour personne on devait de l'argent
c'est jouer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on choisit s'il vous plaît c'est trois
personnes
qui sont là de la France
[Musique]
mais je vous aime bien quand même
les chéris j'avais choisi toi que papa
j'en veux des règles précises
je gagne tu perds
de quelques manières que ce soit c'est
très simple on n'est pas que ça à [ __ ]
non plus tu fais glisser ton téléphone
c'est terminé pour toi beneyme si tu
arrives là c'est très bien si ça tombe
là si ça tombe là
on verra
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je déciderai je décidais ultérieure
pour l'instant je demande à voir je
demande dans quelles conditions et le
téléphone le public trouve-t-il que je
suis juste oui
merci en public
qu'est-ce qui se passe qu'est-ce qui se
passe
tu peux aller rejoindre ta maman
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
et ça ne changera pas aujourd'hui
Hanouna galon comme le verre
à peu près où je suis écoute-moi bien
alors maintenant
nous n'avons pas élevé les raloufs
ensemble
[Rires]
et Benaim je te dis une chose non mais
je vais te dire quelque chose médaille
déjà tu vas baisser d'un ton parce que
je peux baisser dans ton petit bonhomme
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qui fait que moi j'ai baissé
d'un ton alors que moi si je te demande
de baisser d'un ton c'est pour des
raisons pécuniaires de concernant
merde tu sais j'ai été connu au départ
au Magalie et hors de question que ça
change aujourd'hui Benaim va commencer
tu as les
Ribes quand même
Benaim vas-y lance ton téléphone si
Benaim Gan je rappelle que tout le monde
perd même les brebis galeux
si je
gagne les produits gagnants que pendant
que vous serez tranquillement en
week-end sur une chaise longue ça glisse
vachement en train de vous tartiner les
pieds avec de l'huile solaire je suis
tranquillement ici en train d'en chier
avec les rats d'animaux
ont choisi de ne rien gagner les gens
ont changé de vivre dans la souffrance
la tête il vaut mieux avoir la tête
haute et le zizi bas
mais c'est vrai
est-ce que je suis là en sécurité auquel
cas vous avez pas de pression ou il y a
pas de sécurité du tout sécurité
pour vous
vas-y Benaim
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est terminé donc alors moi je vais
devoir tirer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai pris tous les risques pour vous
mais je voudrais vous remercier de
m'avoir donné cet amour
j'aime la France la France me le rend
bien merci la France et si j'ai gagné ce
jeu c'est terminé
[Musique]
tu sais tu peux te la mettre ta
galanterie
en tout cas il va pouvoir partir en
vacances
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le cinéma
[Rires]
[Musique]
on choisit
de suivre et de soutenir Valérie Benaim
dans la voie de l'honneur
et du chômage
la voix de l'échec de la louze mais Naïm
ça tient en trois syllabes rien de plus
Benaim vous avez perdu le premier point
en faisant un jeu dégueulasse
parce que je rappelle le principe
qui va être lisser glisser glisser
glisser glisser s'il dépasse c'est perd
le pupitre
sur le plateau d'une autre émission
[Rires]
moi j'ai fait un jeu où j'ai pris un
certain risque qu'on l'envoyant
de démarrer la deuxième
pour le deuxième point parce que deux
points apparemment
même si si j'ai une règlement des jeux
du système
le règlement qui est là article 1 cyril
a le droit d'ajouter autant de règles
qu'il
[Musique]
chaque nouvelle règle ajoutée par Cyril
est acceptée par la Fédération de ce
système ça a été article
3e comme adversaire
article 4 tout adversaire qui est
offusqué par une règle de Cyril sur un
sanctionner
[Rires]
exactement
à la fin du jeu
[Applaudissements]
c'est dur c'est dur mais c'est juste
vive la France vive le Charles de Gaulle
je vais m'en doute démarrer pourquoi ce
deuxième point c'est ici un smartphone
[Rires]
[Musique]
à descendre tout va démarrer
il y a pas de hasard
par le pouvoir de la reine
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle a touché mon téléphone
je n'ai pas je n'ai pas rappelé ce qu'il
y avait à gagner pour le public
que le public
partira grâce à la boxe de Wonder en
week-end
[Rires]
il y a 3000 séjours disponibles
donc on est d'accord que vous ne rejouez
pas
le droit de toucher mon téléphone
de Valérie
[Applaudissements]
je sais que tu viens d'arriver et que tu
veux garder ta porte bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
tu as gagné non non
elle a gagné c'est pour moi non mais
rejoins
[Musique]
par le pouvoir du gars
alors
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il rentre dans la tête de l'adversaire
il essaie de me fragiliser
je suis avec toi merci
non je préférerais pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
nous dit
[Musique]
meurt il meurt
non non non
toute façon
rien du tout mais si l'avatar va
chercher un fils de sang elle y va elle
ira jamais sur la bande tu peux
l'enlever
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est perdu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est incroyable c'est terminé le
public a gagné
[Applaudissements]
des trois personnes qui vont se faire
chier à Paris
comment vous appelez François Charlotte
Valentin Sofiane les trois les chéris si
vous voulez partir en weekend ce sera de
la poche de Benaim ça aide de voir
alors allez vous asseoir déjà parce que
quand on a une défaite aussi pitoyable
que ça soit
quand on a été aussi nul
les chéris malheureusement j'ai des
bonnes et des mauvaises nouvelles
sachez qu'en fait
je vous ai malheureusement menti
tout le monde gagne
je le dis c'est pour moi et ça me fait
extrêmement plaisir y compris mes
copains non non
sachez les chéris que je vous ai ramené
pour chacun
une chouquette
[Applaudissements]
c'est la règle malheureusement c'est la
règle
c'est moi qui décide
je t'adore mais malheureusement les
règles sont claires ici la direction
j'ai actuellement la direction de H2O la
boîte de production et c'est vous la
direction de H2O oui j'ai actuellement
la direction actuellement qui me dit non
je vais vous dire la vérité
j'aurais bien voulu malheureusement ma
déontologie
[Applaudissements]
le principe et mes principes
je vous le dis tout le public
sauf 3
[Applaudissements]
ce n'est rien je ne fais que mon métier
j'aimerais que tous les vainqueurs se
lèvent aïe aïe aïe
il y en a trois encore assis
de consolation car je suis quand même
gentil je sais qu'à Noël on aime bien
mettre l'ambiance je vous offre à chacun
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
et j'apprendront à l'avenir que la vie
est faite de choix
la vie est faite de choix et parfois le
destin fait que quand on fait un choix
et bien ça va influencer tout le reste
de notre vie moi j'ai fait le choix de
tricher
de la win et j'ai fait le choix être
toujours droit dans mes bottes alors
Valérie tu crois pas que ce serait plus
simple de demander pardon
je pense également Jean-Marie si tu as
raison voilà maintenant on va pas
rentrer là-dedans Valérie et tu veux que
je te dis je respecte ton choix je
respecte ton talent je respecte
également voilà aujourd'hui que tu sois
aujourd'hui que tu sois aujourd'hui
rejetez pas le public
mais vraiment exceptionnellement je vous
disais tout le bien que je pense de vous
à genoux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes toutes pardonné
ou c'est la magie de Noël et je vous
offre mes boules de Noël illuminer
[Rires]
c'est magnifique sur le sapin vous allez
voir je vais aller passer à Noël
délicieux qu'est-ce que je pourrais vous
dire écoutez
rien restez comme vous êtes soyez mon
ami ah mais je serai votre ami pour
toujours bravo du coup alors
malheureusement
j'ai gagné c'est fini c'est sûr parce
que j'étais tout le portable était sur
la dernière fois
c'est juste derrière c'est juste
derrière quand on est quand on est au
deuxième on est 2e c'est quand même
sinon
il y aurait des premiers malheureusement
la vie est faite qu'il y a des premiers
à des 2e l'année dernière vous êtes
comme DJ vous gagnez tout le temps
magnifique mais c'est la loose quand
même
extraordinaire
malheureusement et je le dis et je le
dis malheureusement pour vous je vous
adore vraiment je n'ai rien contre vous
vraiment ça m'a fait extrêmement plaisir
de voir mais malheureusement je vous ai
rayé de ma vie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
privée
malheureusement ce que vous m'avez fait
la trajectoire
je l'ai là
et je peux vous dire que je n'oublierai
jamais c'est super bon les chéris on a
quand même une émission à faire pour
l'instant on continue là on passe à
autre chose ils ont leur vie tu as
quasiment
Cyril selon les règles de la Fédération
vous avez dit que vous pouviez modifier
la règle
c'est les règles du 6 à 7 on était dans
Touche pas à mon poste c'est qu'il y a
du sucre
avec tout le cœur que j'ai
beaucoup fait avec plaisir
malheureusement
le règlement dit non c'est faux je suis
un homme de droit il y a que trois mecs
rien
[Rires]
je ne peux pas croire que dans votre
grande magnitude
franchement
c'est à peu près 3000 € 4000 €. ah ouais
c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
merci